this past weekend we got video let's
bust this donkey dick down baby here we
go coming on my side cam and alright I'm
home
not really I'm in Dallas Monday August
14th Monday August 14th and it's this
past weekend celebrate dark days that's
what they say right there and that's the
Spencer Jacob growl band GRA you and
they have that interest song that they
made for me a while back still grateful
of those guys I'll try to remember to
put the link on the YouTube this weekend
but it's there in spirit if sometimes
you don't see the link on the page it's
there in spirit
happy Monday happy middle of August can
you believe it do you believe in August
you better manage wrapping its arms
around you right now you know and I'm
here in Dallas Texas and I am in a
Intercontinental I think the hotel is
called it's good the elevators are
really slow when you get in the elevator
and I don't like an elevator you know if
you know me you normal fashion I like
staircase you know I remember a time
when if you are a handicap you just
waited at the bottom of the stairs until
some strong boys or a strong lady or two
would would carry you up if you had to
get up to a different floor you know and
I think that was a more romantic time
and some people are like oh well that's
that's crazy or whatever you're crazy
okay
you've been eating crazy sauce check
your gums for CS residue baby because I
haven't been eating crazy sauce I'm
saying that if you're handicapped you're
sitting at the bottom of the stairs
right and there's nothing wrong with
being handicapped dude in the future
people that are handicapped will rule
the world and but if you're handicapped
you're sitting at the bottom of a
staircase somebody comes along right
they're going to help you
they're going to help you and when they
help you you're going to feel helped
they're going to feel like they helped
someone and those are great feelings you
know and that's immediately people are
connecting you know maybe you're going
to the third or fourth floor maybe you
you guys sweat a little
you know maybe they have you thrown over
their shoulder and you you know let out
some body gas you accidentally have a
little bit of body gas that comes out or
something and it doesn't make anybody a
bad person it just I think times like
that brought people closer together you
know back when you know if you were
walking past the staircase and you saw
you know somebody that was H capped or
something sitting down at the bottom or
somebody that you know had a limp or
something you know they couldn't get up
the stairs you were able to help them
and it made you feel good man and it
made them feel good and that's how a lot
of friendships probably started back in
the day whereas now you get into a cold
box and it takes you ever you need to go
and you get out and you still have your
handicap and the person who had the
opportunity to help you they're still
they didn't get to help anybody and so
everybody's maybe feeling you know a
little less connected than they were
back in the old days you know
back when uh when you just waited at the
bottom of the stairwell for a kind man
or strong man or strong women a couple
of strong women to scoop you up and get
you to where you needed to go but the
elevators don't work in here that's what
I'm trying to say they don't work very
well at this hotel you get there and
then there's literally about a four
second delay before the doors open and
lets you add into the hallway that's a
long time it's a long time for when
you're just there's already that awkward
energy in an elevator I feel
uncomfortable in elevators and I long
have and I used to think that it was
other people making me feel
uncomfortable now I know that it's me
it's me who is just naturally born
filled with uncomfort you know I mean if
I was a doughnut I'd be an uncomfortable
with uncomfort cream and that's how just
how I think I made you know the
ingredients in me I mean you're looking
at six seven eight cups of discomfort
out of the gate but I'm happy to be here
with you guys today man thank you guys
for joining me I hope you had a good
weekend I know you know I'll tap into
the news
and I'm here in Dallas you know I'm here
in the south
even though Texas is its own universe it
really is managed
Texas is extraordinarily diverse I find
you know there's a lot of diversity here
and and you know this weekend was just
crazy the Charlottesville stuff popped
up and that's on everybody's mind I'm
not going to go into it much I think
it's my immediate thoughts were that
this is sad and that this is ignorant
those are my immediate thoughts you know
the idea of anybody thinking that that
their small group rules the universe or
runs the world it's just it's it's a
name you know it's it's ignorant and
when it gets to these levels where
people are protesting and stuff it's
just pretty ridiculous and it's it's
really old-fashioned too if you will you
know I'm not trying to minimalize it but
it's just it's like really you know and
it's ignorant that's what I thought I'd
look at these ignorant people but then
I'm wondering well who are these other
ignorant people who if you know severely
ignorant people are going to be
somewhere that you're showing up to
protest severe ignorance you know in the
media is saying that it's a couple of
thousand not that many people you know
you have a few hundred you know
pitchfork monsters out there and let
them go let them have their say let them
wave their flags and say what they want
to say and then let it disperse but then
you have also people who I get I don't
understand the reason
if knuckleheads are out and about I stay
inside because you don't say
knuckleheads if you go out and you meet
up with a knucklehead in the street
you're a knucklehead it doesn't I'm not
saying your views are right compared to
their so that your views are wrong
compared to theirs but that's dumb you
know I'm saying if somebody's out in the
street with weaponry and ignorance you I
promise you I'll be inside drinking
sweet tea or or uh making homemade
butter nor being inside do a monopoly or
something you know we're making candles
are doing a homemade Woodworks you're
not going to catch me on the side I'm
not going to catch a case ignorance so I
just don't understand some of that I
just don't understand why give these
people attention and then the media
comes and gives them mass attention mass
attention so now you have the whole
world thinking that this is who America
is and that's the media's fault that way
that's not true you know and it's just
man it makes me mad I wish somebody
would just come out with a news
organization or any type of
entertainment that was just real based
in reality they didn't have a political
agenda that didn't have a political
point of view because I just mean it
makes me sad when you see the rest of
America you see the rest of America
being like we're not [ __ ] have
anything to do with these people you
know it makes the South look ignorant
which i think these days sometimes is a
goal it's a goal sometimes of these
mainstream media outlets to make the
South seem ignorant you know I don't
know just really sad it made me think
wow these dudes definitely didn't get
the fraternity they were rushing for you
know I mean these fellows ah I mean it's
just farming some of it was just so
funny and ridiculous
but then they take these photos they put
them at angles to make it look like
there's a million people out there you
know when it's probably 400 people or
300 none of them even don't have an uber
app they all drove they'd only be there
for a couple hours they're probably
paying pretty good money for parking is
it was a premium area they were in you
know you know after $24 of parking
expenses they're not going to be out
there anymore
so I don't let them spend that parking
money and go but but I just feel like
the media creates so much more than
there really is
it makes our country look so bad and
that's disheartening
you know it's disheartening because it's
just not the truth so I think it's all
my feelings were you know that just it
made me feel sad it made me feel sad and
it made me feel if you're if you
ignorant is in the street you go out
there man it's hard to say you ain't a
little bit ignorant you know so
it's just sad what happened you know
people died there was a helicopter crash
and then police officers have to go and
be out there now you have police
officers who are in unsafe conditions
it's just some of the selfishness and
ignorance is just beyond me you know but
man the media blood on their hands I'm
the media should be tried in a court of
law I do not understand how you can
continually scare people
you know because 150 dudes in
Charlottesville Virginia it's not that
scary really you know if you let those
guys loose against a real pack of any
type of group of people that they hate I
mean even probably 40 strong gay dudes
or whip those people's ass you know and
instead you give them all this attention
to make it seem like they're something
special so just disheartening man but
but we go on you know and you know we
you know maybe you lift some of these
people up and thought in your thoughts
you put them up in prayers you know but
we go on you know we go on and we have
things to take our mind off of things
you know this weekend I went to you know
I'm big into the Lee Harvey Oswald you
know I'm big in lho the alleged killer
of John F Kennedy and I'm here in Dallas
where he kind of really you know
polished up his uh really finished off
his career if you will even though he
went to middle school in my hometown and
I'm not a fan of Lee Harvey Oswald but I
am there's some I'm sure there's a
little bit of infatuation there I think
it's interesting you know so today we
went to the Book Depository me and a
friend of mine went to the Book
Depository and she was chatting man
sometimes you get with somebody they
just may not like I want fun like what
am I even listening to anymore you know
is there a b-side to this person can I
get at least a remix you know do you
know another language at least I just
just continue to just Gavin Gavin gab
but can we do it in Spanish or Slovakian
or salaka back in you know
so to be a good listener man but we're
in there man and it's pretty wild you
get in a Book Depository you know and
you are and you see where you know Lee
Harvey was and where the crack these
shots off of I put it on my Instagram if
you want to check out it's a view that's
the angle that's the view that's the
distance coming out of an iPhone you can
check it out and so that was pretty wild
man but I recommend it if you get here
to Dallas check out the Book Depository
and you go check out them in the
Metellus what you need to check out is
the boarding the home the the boarding
house that Lee Harvey was at because Lee
Harvey seemed like kind of a small
little if these ATB a guy who was in a
like krav maga but not like now but like
50 years ago you know like small wiry
you know fiery ah you know yet his wife
staying in a house nearby
he was standing a boarding house I mean
you get to go to the boarding house so
if you go to the boarding house you get
to see what was going on in the actual
boarding house and the girl whose family
ran the boarding house when Lee Harvey
stayed there
she still now operates the museum that
the boarding house has turned into and
she gives you tours so you can talk to
her and think with her and see what some
of her thoughts are but after a lot of
uh you know a lot of investigation I
think it's hard to think that Lee Harvey
didn't do it so that's where I stand
I've had some people reach out to me and
ask and that's where I stand with that
what else is going on man I'm a week off
of the pornography so I'm feeling pretty
good I'm feeling V rile a little bit but
I can feel just over my shoulder
sometimes I can feel he you know unknown
titties or foreign breasts or you know
wild cooter or you know uh you know
dirty teams.com just lurking on the nape
of my neck so I have to be careful I
have to be careful because I'm trying to
stay off of the pornography and just
keep it out of my life you know I start
to think that I'm better than that you
know now if you're 25 years old you're
spraying out you know when you lending
yourself a hand every now and then you
know
saying you're uh you know you you're um
you're putting your body and you put
your nuts to work and your vas deferens
you know you turn them into some
straight-up snipers sniping out you know
just skeet now living life and that's
okay but if you find that you have some
sort of addiction to it or some sort of
issue then hold the line brother go for
a walk breathe deep you know I'm saying
put ice in your mouth that's what my
buddy used to do you know when my
buddies actually his mother taught us
that his mother one time knew we were
hiding up in the house one weekend and
doing masturbation and so she took a
bunch of ice and put it in our mouths
and I don't know what it does to you but
I mean I'll tell you this I've never
lived through a strong winter but I
don't think I could jerk off you know in
a snowstorm
I don't think I could do masturbation in
an avalanche because there's something
about it it just shuts down your your
desire to um to self spray do self spray
so anyhow man I'm here in Dallas I had a
good weekend I want to thank everybody
that came out you know we had a good
squad that came out a lot of people saw
some friends man I had friends people
that drove in from Kansas that came out
and vomited in them and the bar
afterwards but nice people you know
indecent vomit real hearty hearty birth
of vomit flew out of this lady and I
remember when I was young the first time
I ever vomited and I was I'd been having
peanut butter and jelly and I woke up in
the middle of the night and my dent and
I just was vomiting I just probably
spraying hot on the wall and and my mom
is yelling I'm screaming I'm crying my
mother comes in and she's like what's
what's going on you know and I'm just
like my dinner is flying out of my face
you know I just didn't have a concept of
of puking you know I'm just my dinner
just does not want to be with me and so
she helped me clean it up and then put
me back to sleep but I remembered as
being scared after that to eat for a
while
because I was scared to know if certain
foods wanted to live inside of my body
you know but what else man what else is
going on in the world you know Joe Rogan
had his birthday this past week you know
I don't think if you guys caught that I
think it was on Thursday or Friday but I
want to give a shout out to him and Coco
Diaz spoke with him the other day and I
am name-dropping here but I'm just I
feel blessed to kind of be in a be able
to take knowledge from these guys you
know when it comes to podcasting or
thinking or just making me feel like a
part of the business that I love of
stand-up comedy so I hope we have a
million more years of Joe Rogan if you
haven't listened to Joe Rogan I suggest
you check into him he's the strongest
sponge I think that we have out there
these days and I say that in the sense
that that man likes to you know he likes
to be strong and he likes to absorb and
uh and there's a good ways to be a
minute he's an inspiring dude and Coco
if you don't know Coco Diaz man you look
I know if you've had hot coco if you
like that you need to try this hit a
spicy Coco
Joey Coco Diaz all right before we get
into a couple of calls here I want to
let you know the hotline number again is
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three you can hit the hotline
discussing anything we're talking about
you can start a topic idea of your own
if you want to floor one for the next
episode and that's pretty much it man I
appreciate the calls we've had a lot of
great ones some of them I'm saving for
future episodes that we're kind of
piecing together and some of them you
know just hits at the right time and so
we're going to use it then but I'd
greatly appreciate it all right let's
get to some calls you know we had a girl
that called in last week and she was
talking about how she had hairy arms
when she was young and that she got made
fun of a lot for those hairy arms and
since then she's always shaved her arms
down
and here it is 15 20 years later and I
bet if she saw the people who had made
fun of arms they wouldn't even remember
anymore because people forgetful animals
do you know I mean we leave we you know
we leave we leave memories everywhere
people are forgetful animals but that
she you know that if she ran into people
they wouldn't remember that she still
remembers that she carries that with her
and so we got a lot of calls that came
in but I do want to thank everybody that
came out in a Dallas this weekend man
out a great time
big respect out to my boy Steve Oh DJ yo
that came through who else
little geet my sure hooked me up with
some camera guys that came out beautiful
fellows man one of the boys had
beautiful eyes when I'm had beautiful
hair I mean he had the Falls coming off
the back you know when it takes it takes
balls to grow the falls man I'll say
that okay it takes rocks to drop the
locks baby in a few if you're not
growing the back to your hair out and
you never have
then just try it you know I know this
haircut looks like something that the
dog cult you know or something maybe
you'll wake up and there might be a bird
living in you know that a seamstress
might come and kind of pluck a little
bit off the back of your scalp off the
upper nape of your neck so she can have
a little bit extra thread to do her deed
okay I know that I know there's nothing
clutch or or you know savvy about coming
in with this but I'll tell you this when
you show up with that gutter cut when
you show up with that gun chopped
boo-boo people know that you mean
business people know that you mean
business and I'll tell you that my life
has soared since I have not been afraid
to try something new if it says
something as small as a haircut or you
know even just choose enough to pick my
nose while I Drive I'm making changes in
my life what are you doing what are you
doing so let's get to some of those
calls man I know we're getting to them
early today but that's it
you know that's it they're great I'm
gonna give you a couple of quick day
really fast I will be at the cap city
comedy club in Austin September 6
through 7 I'll be at hilarities in
Cleveland September 14th through 17th
and I'll be in Huntsville Alabama at
stand-up live that's November 16th
through the 19th you can get the two
albums that are out thirty to come bag
of hamster bones and must get fire on
iTunes and you can grab you can grab
some other stuff that's on theof on comm
slash store or we got some great calls
man like I said the colors were hitting
us up in response to if somebody said
something to you that you then lived
your life by it or felt you know it
hurts your feelings it affected the way
that you viewed yourself and you carried
those those behaviors on for a long time
you know and I've had them
I've had them I'll get to sell my man
look crack into this this is old poop
eyes calling us let's hear you hey old
man big fan um I just podcast and you
stand up so yeah I'm from Gulfport
Mississippi actually so I guess that
gentleman wanted the subpoena behind the
gray half station yeah
he's referencing I um there was a
gentleman I met from Gulf ports on a
during a Greyhound bus you know life
adventure who was trying to uh you know
touch me off with the insides of his
mouth you know who was trying to do you
know inner wall and tongue favors with
his mouth onto my body and thankfully I
was ain't made it out of that but that's
a typical greyhound you know something
that can happen at some of the stops
while you're just trying to get a
Gatorade or live your life but uh but
anyhow Gulfport Mississippi
I actually hitchhiked out of there one
time to South Carolina chasing an
ex-girlfriend ended up petting her
somebody's cat on her porch in the
middle of the night in Charleston and
thank God realized that I had was
borderline about to turn into a stalker
so anyhow onward thank you for calling
brother from Gulfport onward
got some people there we were talking
about on the podcast should that
impacted your life when you were younger
well my mom when I was like five years
old
it was a joke around the house to tell
me I had poopy brown I said okay he said
their joke around the house he had poopy
brown eyes poopy broom like my eyes were
Brown so I went to school and when the
teacher was asking you know what colors
ever launched eyes people were like blue
and green and I said kooky brown because
I really thought poopy was a shade of
brown and yes I put telling people my
color was spooky Browns but that
impacted my life but it was embarrassing
so I just wanted to share that thanks
man I appreciate you sharing that man
that [ __ ] visuals you had and that you
were feeling that and yeah I mean it's
funny because you'll hear something
you'll think it's okay to say anything
you'll share it you know and yeah I can
imagine that'd be weird you know for
years you got them poopy brown eyes you
know you got them ah you got them
what's it called you got that diarrhea
dilators you know people saying oh man
he got that you know he must be needing
kale you know he must've been having a
few beets because his eyes are setting
it off with that bootie gravis style you
know and I can feel that man I
appreciate you sharing that because
that's a real thing you know it's wild
when we were young how somebody tells
you one thing and then it changes you
forever somebody told me that I looked
like a doonesbury character one of those
characters from some cartoon and they're
kind of dead in the eyes and you know
when I'm you know half polish so mild
when you're half polish your eyes you
know that this area your face only comes
in at about 70 watts you know you're not
running on a hundred watts like other
people are like a lot of you know like
you'll see some people sometimes from
Venezuela Ecuador you know Russ you
there running high wattage up here in
the optical area but you get the Polish
man they're coming in around 70 watts in
the eyes you know you don't want you to
see what they're thinking you know they
want to keep the stage dimly lit even
though sometimes is a lot of activity
going
there's a lot of dialogue running behind
the curtains but but I appreciate that
man you know you had them poobahs other
people had wild stuff I remember they
had a boy in our town a young brother
young black child named doodoo brown
they called him doodoo brown and if you
had poop eyes mention this boy had a
hole I guess I'm assuming this entire
poop physique and everything and I don't
know how he caught the name or not but
he really he really had it you know he
really had a young doodoo brown they
called him Richard I think was his name
and then he at one point somebody gave
him a pair of church socks and he would
wear the church socks during basketball
and he never had the right shoes he
always had on you know sometimes not
even the same shoe so you see him out
there on the basketball court one
sneaker one cowboy boot church socks
flying out of him and that's when people
started calling him dressed to kill DTK
and they would yell dressed from the
sidelines every time you get the ball
dress and the board would get so nervous
that he just couldn't even deal with his
own life you know dressed to kill I
don't know whatever happened to him you
know but I'm down he turned into quite
the haberdasher because he probably was
afraid to live you know to live or to
wear anything I mean hell he could just
be wearing a onesie these days and I
wouldn't blame him because it's the
things that people tell us sometimes
that resonate with us forever you know
and that just it's waiting you don't
know when it's going to be you don't
know what years of your life like or
what moments until years later it's so
crazy you know it's just so wild but I
appreciate you calling in man and uh and
you know I'm sure you got decent eyes
dude you know I'm sure you got decent
eyes bro so good luck out there all
right let's take another color here hey
Theo it's your boy Tom in rural North
Carolina I just listened to your last
this past weekend about insecurity and
when I was like wow Tom's not polish man
Tom's coming in heated there you feel
that he's got that bailamos in him he's
got that you know that he's got that um
you know like somebody historically and
his family was hiding gun powder under
their tongue
you know we're filling or or you know or
maybe doing a cinnamon suppositories or
something something up their game he's
full you can hear the life in him
alright he's got that Dolby surround
sound coming out of his face let's hear
it keep going when I was a kid like
third grade
I grew up overweight so I had man boobs
and as a kid how he's real good
that was real great that makes me an
easy target yeah kid titties they call
them kids hit and you'll see a lot of
boys with them kids hits and sometimes
are hotter than some of the breasts that
are out there on that you actually end
up touching oh I didn't want to tell
this story but I remember when we first
started seeing breasts and tits they
called them both things back then
breasts and I think breasts and tits and
I remember this fella in our town had
some I mean and I hate to say it I'm not
you know if he had beautiful beautiful
tits on him for and as a child I could
recognize it like my god you know if you
had just been able to cut off like his
head and the rest of his body below his
breast and his arms and just put that
other little rectangle into a contest
that could have won a beautiful a
beautiful kind of pale but still
beautiful tipped contest because this
boy had some just glamour manners on
them I mean just I mean just sunlit I
mean it just seemed like somebody just
caught two little handfuls of sunlight
and just shaped them into just sweet
nippled meets beautiful this kid had
this kid had beautiful tits on him and
and I remember one time even in a pool
kind of when I was going through those
times when you start to get those
squirrels running through your body when
you feeling a little bit electric and
you feel them sex inside of you when you
start feeling it I remember in the pool
I would repeatedly grab onto this boy's
chest
and just be like we were wrassling you
know but I knew in my head that I was
being sexual with him in some way I know
that's crazy man but I just wanted to
share that but thank you for calling it
medicine about me onward we were
standing the lunch line and because of
like your bigger breasts and women all
this fit that to this day um I just
never liked it
did I guys I've lost over like 200
pounds in my adult life and I just never
forgotten that and it's led me down the
row with that wedding
okay lost 200 pounds on you so you
really did so it probably you had the
weight issues impacting it as well
onward it's just like a real big kid as
I got older just the insecurities never
left
I needed me to take TRT running multiple
cycles of d-ball okay so no steroids now
onward I think it's to the point now
we're like I could be big enough I grew
up very very insecure but now I try to
project almost the opposite of I'm just
very big and I'm very aggressive and
very strict not me I think about and
have those little securities looking
over been a very different person what
nicer person a lot nicer to look at so
now I'm just in the gym 20 hours a week
quite literally um taking your strongest
testosterone just out of fear
that's not insecurity it's a tree deep
one to this day I looked myself in the
mirror and I just think I look small and
I look terrible so it was like a true
body just more for you that that those
two boys really inflicted and a thanks
to the podcast
love you bro wow man love you too man I
want to say that and this call really
reflects reflects with me man I can
really relate to this and I don't if you
guys heard some of the things that he
said I'm hoping that you did because you
you know you have ears I did go straight
to your brain and you know you have
jurisdiction over those holes but he was
saying that people made fun of the way
he looked and he was young and so it
impacted him so much that years later
he's taking steroids and then when he
looks in the mirror sometimes he feels
like he's whoever he is
it's not even really him that he would
be totally different maybe if he weren't
caught in this you know cycle if you
will of having to feel like he had to be
big or built or jacked or geeked up on
that protein and man I can relate to
this hundred percent dude that sounds
like you know something very much happen
to me when I was young I was extremely
thin when I was young I heard had a
basketball coach one time that called me
a name it was a nickname but it made me
feel really thin and uh and I had a big
butt too so I had always been big in the
glutes I've had that kind of either a
you know kind of a black girl's butt or
kind of a even a Down syndrome my buddy
dari and I had the same but I've talked
about that before I had that kind of D s
booty and so years later I remember
being in high school and somebody had
steroids a buddy of mine who was a
homosexual and he ended up doing pills
and driving into an embankment but we
got into using using we got him using
some steroids and it made me feel I just
didn't have to think about that anymore
I didn't for the first time ever I felt
okay with how I looked even though I
probably looked like an idiot you know I
probably you know I'm already have never
been really long in the neck and I'm
actually considering getting a um a neck
brace a children's neck brace to get
started with that you know when I
probably put about three quarters of an
inch in my neck by maybe February or
March of uh of length and but anyhow so
yeah man I can totally sympathize I
appreciate you calling in and and just
voicing that because that's real man you
know when I got caught up using steroids
for honestly probably a few years on and
off
and I just never felt okay and then the
steroids would make me feel crazy I got
in a fight one time young brother stole
an album one time at this party and next
you know melt swing him with this kid
and throwing hands and just that was in
college I remember
is getting abusive and angry sometimes I
would get drunk getting angry towards
women at times when I was drunk you know
we're just mixing you don't realize at
that point you just mixing things up but
the biggest thing was is over the years
then years later I remember thinking wow
you know I don't know if whoever I truly
am is even somebody that wants to spend
that much time in the gym you know I
think in my heart of hearts I think I
would rather be you know somebody who
probably does a little bit more yoga a
little bit more of an artist or maybe to
be honest broad thing I could have been
a damn dancer bro real talk dude some of
them I think I had that footwork I mean
I see a hummingbird sometime then I'd be
like man I know this [ __ ] you
know what I'm saying you know I'd see
some of those videos with that Fred
Astaire or the Shirley Temple and I feel
like man I got I can do that footwork
you know like I just felt like if I had
the smallest heels on and I showed up on
a pale-faced baby then I could leave a
30 seconds later and I just have
freckled prints all I could leave
freckles on that young stallion you know
that I've had the ability to do things
that I could have been a dancer
sometimes but do you can't say that kind
of [ __ ] somewhere environment you're
growing up in you know when everybody
else around you is tough or you know
they got proper food at home and you're
eating cereal and then that's you know
you're just not bringing on the calories
and whatever you need or whatever but I
appreciate you sharing man that's crazy
but I can feed to look in the mirror and
know that man let me Know Who I am and
I'm so caught up in this I just got to
keep going but I will say this for me
over time it's gotten better in these
days if I can make a yoga class three
days a week
I'm just taking me until Here I am in my
later 30s but if I can get a yoga class
three days a week I feel like I'm almost
back where I need to be you know that
I'm finally kind of just just starting
to really kind of grow up then for some
reason I had all these demons out a ride
over for a while so sorry to get serious
but I appreciate you calling in about
that man man oh I'm tired guys I know
it's you know I can't
tell if this is a good podcast or not I
have no idea
it's 1:00 a.m. here and and I got to be
out of here at 5:30 hit the air but uh
but I'm happy to be here within them and
keep it going we got another call right
here but thank you so much for calling
man you know and I wish you you know if
you're still involved in that and still
using them Roy's I wish you I wish you
the best in finding a way out of it
because I remember when my arms would
start getting smaller immediately I
would feel less than you know in these
days still I worry about some of the
side effects you know like extra hair on
my back or you know I don't have any
anger or anything like that anymore side
effects but you know extra hair on my
back
what else would I think oh one of my
nuts one time felt a little bit square
for a little while but that could have
been seasonal as well but let's take
another call here we go
hey what up if this is do is this is
Jason uh out of Texas I just wanted to
say I was assistant to your podcast and
you said something about us that
everybody thinks southern there's eight
farms and strangle fish or something and
yeah it's true everybody thinks
southerners it's like like we're nothing
you know like we're idiots or we're this
or that a lot of great southerners man a
lot of amazing great southerners you
know or just Americans is which is
really a cool way to think about them
onward I laugh my ass off and you're
right but uh who gives a [ __ ] what they
think and don't mean we're ignorant you
know I'm from the south when I go to
California they think I'm from Tennessee
or something my clothes but you know
sector but anyways I just wanted to say
that is that [ __ ] was funny
keep it up bro you keep people like me
that's what attracted me to you is that
southern drawers like somebody that'd be
peace thanks man I appreciate it yeah
I'm stuck with how I sound man you know
and four years out in Hollywood I try to
change the way that I sounded I try to
change the way that I felt
because I just didn't think I could get
any work I couldn't then we're going to
let a guy like me have any work I didn't
look around and see any other
southerners or Midwesterners catching
any catching anybody that was like me
making it in Hollywood and I still don't
these days you know I mean I can't
really and it does it makes me mad
sometimes I feel like it doesn't make me
mad but it it used to make me mad it
does well let me be clear about what I'm
feeling it makes me upset it makes me
feel unwanted a little bit you know but
I can't help it I was born with the way
that I sound you know it's crazy it's
like in Hollywood they'll say you know
embrace who you are and live your true
self and do this and do that but then
you tell that to a boy you know and he
makes it all the way to Hollywood and he
gets there and he shows up and you know
in 15 years later he's still doing his
art and he's and he's and he's doing
well at it and then for people to still
think oh this guy is this way or this
guy is that way or this guy's an idiot
or this guy's you know just because he
sounds away he does maybe we wouldn't
have a lot of amazing people if it
weren't for the south we wouldn't have
the Louisiana Purchase we wouldn't have
Mark Twain wouldn't have Walker Percy we
wouldn't have Eudora Welty me there's a
mill you could go on the list goes on
forever we wouldn't have SEC football we
wouldn't have probably half of the NFL
you know I mean those are just a couple
of small elements we wouldn't have if it
weren't for the south you know so it's
like and I know like southern like you
know I'm no rebel flag I'm not in any of
that [ __ ] you know but I think that if
you're going to say that everybody's
welcome let's make everybody welcome you
know because when I look around
Hollywood I don't see anybody like me
you know and that's a little bit scary
it's like what's going on are they
trying to like are we getting rid of
people that that sound southern or that
are from a small town or they're from
the middle of nowhere you know you know
hard it is to get from those places to
the bigger cities and to get to another
level
you know it's a lot easier than I think
it's a lot harder than starting out
right there
oh you were born in New York or born in
LA and you I mean I'm just saying I'm
not I'm not trying to compare real and I
guess I'm getting a little fired up man
but that kind of stuff makes me upset
but I feel you man it doesn't mean we're
ignorant now it doesn't help when they
have people like you know in
Charlottesville that you know that our
are ignorant as [ __ ] it doesn't help us
you know but I think you're right man
you know we just keep shining whatever
our true light is and do our best
because if you take away myself in
accent then what am i you know then how
do I sound to you you know it's like you
want to be accepting of people if be
accepting of them but it's wild man it's
wild of these days it is really wild and
sometimes I feel like in my career path
that I embody this thing that a lot of
people currently hate you know which is
like this these these deplorable zin the
country and maybe it's just a weird
thought that happens about myself
sometimes I don't know I know that I'm
not that but sometimes I feel like
people treat me that way
just because how I sound and it's pretty
sad dude it's like hey people you know
preaching it at rural America to not
judge and be diverse into this and that
but then you know we show up and you
know they just think we all are from
Tennessee you know it's interesting man
it's interesting but hey that's life
right that's where we're at so are let's
catch one more call man you know I
appreciate you guys being here with you
man I'm just I'm getting weird I guess I
kind of know dude I wish you know what I
wish I had a dang gender rail right now
always had maybe some apple juice too
when I was young I used to drink apple
juice and boy I would piss big on apple
juice you know wet the bed laws prob
about 28 years old and I used to piss
big on apple juice and I was used to
stand on grandmas and they had apple
juice up there when daddy got doused up
on that AJ you know what I'm saying when
I got geeked out I'm Johnny a seeds
round red treats you knew
then I was going to guys are up you knew
that let's hear one more question here
or one more call in thank you very much
and thanks for calling in there from
Texas appreciate it I'm happy to be in
your home state today it's a beautiful
place what's up Theo this is Robbie
Lopez from Kansas City Missouri I was a
calling to tell you about a time that
pertained to the most recent Shoni said
to Colin that's why I'm calling
anyway okay I appreciate you calling man
let's get to it but a bear Robbie Lopez
onward there was this girl
it was SuperDuper hot right back in the
day we were all hanging out and I she's
a skinhead girl she's running around the
skinhead dude tonight she had what we
call a Chelsea haircut it was like short
hair whatever beautiful girl a big
dazzling eyes real pretty I'd always
been mean to it she never knew that I
thought she was pretty okay so she had a
skinhead haircut you called it the
Chelsea cut you know that reminds me
when I was growing up they only had one
hairstyle in our town and it was kind of
like a Polish lesbian style and that was
our bus driver who gave us that cut mr.
Rey and he would park the bus and cut
everybody's hair at the same time and
that was a $2.00 cut you got from him
and he kept the shears up there in a bag
under his seat and he stopped the bus on
Thursdays and get everybody's head at
once beautiful ray and he's in heaven
now or in hell I don't know what he did
in his spare time but he seemed
heaven-bound based upon the small
activities I saw him pull off anyhow on
word and I would call our little boys he
should look like a little boy here was
ugly [ __ ] like that never thought
nothing of it because I knew I'd never
have a chance with this chick and uh lo
and behold about eight years later I get
a tap on my shoulder I'm setting up the
bar with some friends and it's a smokin
hot girl and it turns out to be that
girl she tells me I have not forgot
about that since I hated you for so long
all this stuff Wow so she showed back up
into your life huh
that's very much that Carm I don't know
what that is it's maybe human Karma but
not calm
it'sjust I think that's just somebody
showing back up okay tell me more lined
up hanging out change the pattern
section that stuff pays you give him a
complex and you end up weeping over the
rewards
I appreciate this story man you know
that's an interesting thing is given a
girl a complex like that and these have
a book about it
it was just guy Nick somebody it was
like the art of dating or something that
the art of attracting women something
and it was called an egg like if you
gave a woman an egg like a negative
thing then that made it would it would
turn around later and and they would it
would make them feel negative so then
you had an upper hand or something I'm
not sure the psychology behind it but it
ended up getting women attracted to you
so that's interesting man that you told
her you know when she had that short
haircut
you know she was running with that
female fade you know what I'm saying
that UPS worker a lot of female UPS
workers you know sport that top and it
was it's interesting because you know
that doesn't always work that way you
know I remember one time I remember
hearing this when I was in college and I
was not doing swell with the chicas and
this this girl at a club I saw and I was
immediately she was a pretty girl she
seemed nice that's a man that dress
looks horrible on you I know I said you
could do a lot better than that dress
that's what I said and I don't know I
don't think it was my typical behavior I
was just trying something you know I was
trying anything I was susceptible and
she walked off right we'll about four
minutes later these two dudes come over
and they're [ __ ] pissed dude the
guy's like you're being a dick to my
friend this dude slapped me in the neck
okay
I've been hit before I don't know if
you've ever been slapped in the neck but
I mean I felt like a black child in
church because a black mother will slap
a child in the neck you know I'm saying
that neck is a popular destination for a
black mother's hand
and this dude up for the rest tonight in
his bar dude I was too embarrassed to
leave I was like I'm not going to leave
like a little [ __ ] you know but I was
holding I had two drinks I was holding
them against my neck bro to keep the
swelling down so I mean in this case
you're lucky that it worked out that way
I guess
but the issue then is just bigger than
that for me what I see is that the girls
that are going to like that kind of
stuff
something's wrong with them you know and
I'm not saying something wrong with them
long-term but they have an issue you
know they feel like if they get put down
that you know they have some daddy
issues or you know they have you know
they're not they're not emotionally
stable you know the girls that like that
kind of stuff are kind of [ __ ] up you
know you might get laid but but then
what if you end up with a woman like
that is it going to be a healthy
relationship you know an emotionally
stable woman is going to be like [ __ ]
this guy you know this guy has no
self-esteem you know I'm not trying to
put you down I'm just you know I know
you're showing me the other side of what
can happen if somebody tells you
something bad how it can turn out good I
mean in this case it turned out good you
know where you were the one giving some
saying something bad even though you
were just saying because you were you
know you probably were too insecure to
tell her that you liked her and it's
easy to sound confident when you're
being negative so if you give a woman a
negative thing you know what women what
I think is the attractive part is just
being confident and I think in women's
head it gets tripped around like oh he's
confident in at least enough to tell me
something negative so you must be a
confident man you know but you know I
just don't think at long-term that's
easy that's it that's that great you
know and what helps me for approaching
women because my problem is I used to
put women on a pedestal before I even
approached him I think that every woman
was better than me but when are you
approach them you know I'm saying you
pull up and you got a little bit you
throw a little bit of duck in your gut
you know you push you push your butt out
and you you know put your neck long you
know you put a little dunk in your gut
man you show up with a little bit of
quack in your stack you know what I'm
saying you stack your balls that's why
sometimes I do wish my balls were square
you could stack them you said I'm having
a tough time at this moment but I'm not
going into this moment unprepared I'm
going in full fortitude and I'm gonna
stack I'm going to stack my balls before
I walk through this fire that it's
facing me right now and that's what
because that's what women want they want
the confidence you know and I know it's
if I don't post women on a pedestal
first and I just think about them as a
regular person that'll need to have sex
with them I don't need them to like me
but I do want them to know who I am that
that way I find it always works out well
it always works out cleanly because I'm
so grateful that years now I'm not stuck
with someone who is insecure or heavily
insecure we all have some but look eh I
got enough so I need some it's probably
gonna be just a little more secure than
me you know see I think showing up with
and went to a woman and you know just
with that confidence you know you don't
use that negative but hitter with that
confidence wow you look good and you
don't need to say like I need to [ __ ]
you I don't care you know what I'm
saying I'll go home I'll go home and
read a book from a famous southern
author that probably changed the
universe all right I'll go home and
watch interview with a Vampire Diaries
or whatever [ __ ] that was filmed in New
Orleans you know everybody wants to say
the south isn't [ __ ] but they want to
come to our play they want to come to
our areas of the country and use us for
our history in our culture you know they
want to you know it's like you know
every place offers something to this
country you know every place does you
know so I don't know man I think that
maybe that got me a little bent out of
shape tonight so I don't mean to bring
some of those down on you guys but but I
appreciate you call them and I
appreciate you calling with that thought
you know it's interesting you know it's
interesting that that's the way it can
work out sometimes you can do an egg and
I think you know you can nag a woman
give her negative and you know she'll
remember oh that guy was at least
brave enough to not just hit on me you
know he at least just it seemed like he
didn't need me but then if you end up
with that woman that's you know just
start softening it from an unreal place
so I feel it as a way to pick up a chick
if you're trying to get laid
yeah I could definitely work but if you
look for something long-term I'm saying
if you're trying to be an ostrich and
stick your head down in a woman's dirt
for a long period of time you're not
trying to catch a warm but you down
there you know what I'm saying just
looking at the roots seeing what's in
the dirt seeing what's in that woman's
heart and ahead you know if you're gonna
want to be in there for a while then I
don't really recommend that behavior but
I appreciate you calling about it you
know we all have things that people have
said to us in our past that make us feel
a certain way and that build on us I
think a lot of those things worth our
parents sometimes you know my father
always said and this might be a little
bit of a downer but he always said if I
ever let you down that's what my father
said
because I think at his age in his 70s
and going into his 80s that was his
biggest fear you know was having these
young children and them thinking that
that he let us down and I always had to
lie to him man you know I mean I did not
really enjoy my life as a child and I
would always tell me he didn't let me
down you know even though he often did
and so then I think I built up this
thing where I just I was afraid to tell
people when I was not feeling good I was
afraid to tell people when I was hurting
you know I was afraid to tell people
like then I felt insecure about how
skinny I was you know so then I go on in
and up using performance-enhancing drugs
and I were one time had an ex-girlfriend
she found on my steroids and broke them
all come on honey catch daddy's trying
to get them gams you know but in
hindsight thank God man who knows you
know I'm one time I bought some stuff
from some duties home with steroids and
I ate them for like probably about eight
weeks and it was just some kind of
Junior Mints that he had taken all of
the coatings off of some [ __ ] out
there go
when hard in the gym thinking I'm on
performance-enhancing drugs dude and I'm
on damn movie candy so you don't know
what you're getting in this drug market
you know you never have known but some
of that came from you know insecurities
me you know people say look at this
skinny boy people look you know you know
feeling weak afraid to play sports
because I was too weak you know or we
didn't have insurance so if I got hurt
we weren't going to be able to you know
I just be broken you know if I broke my
neck I was just that dude who you know
always had always had his head on it on
one of his shoulders you know if I broke
my clavicle I was going to be that
fellow whose shirt never fit right for
the rest of his life but it left me with
fear you know most of the stuff we do is
out of fear you know people are probably
afraid to get to know southerners
sometimes because maybe they're afraid
maybe they're maybe they're afraid you
know maybe they're afraid that they
won't have as much history as we have or
they won't you know be as kind as we
will you know I don't know you know
people fear runs a lot of things that's
amazing
you know old poop eyes called in man
Madhu ope they call him and you know he
probably was every time he went to the
bathroom he probably was thinking about
his eyes that's bizarre isn't it but
here this dude is just you know on that
rear strain game and he's thinking about
his eyes because there's something
somebody said one time you know it's
crazy the junk we carry you know it's
crazy I'm trying to think of some other
things that happened to me
I mean I have really bad spaces in my
team people make fun of that all the
time
I have medium arms you know somebody
told me I had medium linked arms one
time and guy look at that arm you can
see that I'm not trying to be
charlottesville in here at all I just
put it up in the air sorry but it's a
you know I only have medium length arms
so every time I reach for something you
know if I go get a can of soda it makes
me think about that well damn you know
my way you know what life would be like
if I had an other extra inch a hug
coming out of each on for somebody you
know just crazy where we get left with
you know and how we just we don't know
how to get out of it and I think one
thing we need in this world is to change
our school system man you give like what
are you talking about it's just a vague
blanket statement do yeah it is bro okay
but here's what I'm saying the fact that
people that we don't have a class that
teaches kids how to accept one another
that teaches kids how to share their
feelings if they are feeling a certain
way that teaches kids you know that they
that if they got kid tits how to get
through that you know emotionally so
that they're not running around having
to use drugs and having to compensate
you know I mean I remember one time I
feel like I didn't like my eyelashes so
this lady I was living with had eyelash
curler so for two weeks I was curling my
eyelashes man because I felt like I just
I don't know I mean dang now it sounds
like you know maybe I wanted to be like
you know this uh you know like a young
woman you know but that's not the truth
I just I just hate it just felt inferior
about how I looked you know that's why
you have kids running around doing all
this stuff and that's why you have
people running around racially out of
their brains till with hatred because
something happened to them somebody
taught them something wrong or somebody
said something to them or did something
to them you know I mean I had some
hatred against race when I was young I
got jumped by a bunch of black kids a
couple times man it'll make you mad you
know but that kind of stuff fades after
you realize that a lot of people in
these certain environments are just
angry it doesn't matter what color they
are you know or just there's something
wrong in their lives they're broken too
you know I mean I just can't believe we
don't have a class that helps people
learn certain things because I'm sure
I've sounded very stupid
very ignorant to a lot of people yeah
but I'm out here I'm keeping my eyes
open I'm keeping my poop I got poop
brown eyes bro
no I'm saying I'll go bold I'll show you
my bowls dude
what's in your bowls I'll hit you with
these opticals man these dirty
whirlpools and I want to throw out a
topic for next week before we get out of
here if you know say the world were
we're coming to an end you know as we
know it they got you know these alleged
North Korea threats and I believe that a
lot of that is hype you know I really do
I mean sure you know you have a
president that runs off at the Twitter
handle and you know but I think a lot of
its hype I think North Korea would be
silly to engage in activity that would
ruin what they have going on sure what
they have going on isn't ideal to a lot
of us you know communism but to them it
is and they seem to be getting away with
it so surely they wouldn't want to ruin
that so I think we'll just be ignorant
for them to really start something wild
but I'd like to know say the world is
going to end you know and you have a day
left but what do you do what do you do
with that day you know how do you look
at it what do you you know and I want to
keep it out of the depths the depths of
despair but in a joyous way how you
going to spend that last day what are
you going to do and I'm going to think
about what I would do as well and we'll
go from there so anyhow man I don't mean
to get negative tonight man but you know
sometimes things go where they go and I
hope to get some rest and not and join
with you guys next weekend and I will
try to do some other stuff I'm hoping we
get the studio built this week so that's
great and we're staying at good numbers
man and I appreciate you guys to support
stick with us it's just one week man you
know we're going to do some things man
we're going to do it together and I
appreciate you guys you [ __ ]
beautiful little Ecuadorian mud cats you
know I'm saying I'll squirt frosting up
your grandmother's freaking nose holes
bro
you know I'm saying now blow in her
mouth and just as hard as I can and just
have her just spouting out turn her into
a beautiful sweet cream fountain so if
you got a grandmother man tell them I
love her
tell them I love her and I'm Theo von I
appreciate you guys being here with me
this has been this past weekend I'll see
you guys next week or maybe we'll do a
follow up this week I'm going to try -
all right take care
[Music]
celebrate misery this sad some of the
stuff is going on out there man but
there's also some great stuff going on
out there let's focus on that huh let's
focus on our side of the street you know
I bet all of us have so many good in our
lives if we can just find and we just
got to look so when you get a look might
be somebody small so me not even
recognizing who recognizes a lot of the
value in you appreciate you guys being
here with me be good to yourselves man I
bet you guys deserve it
see you guys next week
[Music]